[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre 7,8
lipdo nous allons faire le tour de la
somme de l'actualité de la semaine dans
les yvelines
le sommaire de ce vendredi 4 octobre
depuis le 24 septembre les députés
discutent la loi bioéthique
son premier article relatif à la pma
pour toutes a été adoptée le 27
septembre
nous parlerons de la procréation
médicalement assistée avec le témoignage
d'une famille homoparentale depuis 20
ans face yvelines agit contre
l'exclusion ce club d'entreprises fêter
son anniversaire au théâtre national de
saint quentin en yvelines jeudi 3
octobre qu'une direction des policiers
en colère et en de lier des enseignants
qui manifestent leur soutien à leur
collègue souci d et la sécurité sociale
qui changent de stratégie
nous reviendrons sur ce qui a marqué les
yvelines cette semaine et avant de
débuter s'était enfin cette édition
cette information une marche blanche en
hommage à natacha une femme de 38 ans
tuée le 1er octobre le principal suspect
et son ex conjoint 111e féminicide
nationale de l'année elle était employée
dans une crèche de marly le roi c'est le
maire de la commune qui invite ses
habitants à se réunir samedi 5 octobre à
10h30 au départ de la crèche des petits
pas muni d'une rose blanche
[Musique]
votants 75 exprimé 72 majorité 37 pour
55 contre 17
l'assemblée a adopté c'était vendredi 27
septembre l'assemblée nationale a adopté
le premier article de loi bioéthique à
savoir l'extension de la pma aux couples
de femmes et aux femmes célibataires 57
voix pour 55 et 17 voix contre le texte
complet sera transmis au sénat le 15
octobre
une mesure qui vise à reconnaître un
fait de société déjà présents nicolas
dans dream a dit le demi ont rencontré
emmanuel projet et mario perrin mère de
trois enfants
bienvenue chez les frogé perrin une
famille homoparentale
il y à emmanuel et marion et leurs trois
enfants augustin né en 2005 et des
jumeaux nils et baptiste arrivé au monde
en 2007
les deux femmes ont eu recours à la
procréation médicalement assistée en
belgique dans s'est adressé à des
cliniques belges en a reçu des réponses
de deux cliniques parmi celles qu'on
avait contacté dont l'une qui est
l'hôpital universitaire
flament 2
belgique de bruxelles qui avait une
procédure qui qui était relativement
simple et qui pouvait surtout nous
prendre rapidement pm1 s'est rendue la
bave toutes les deux pour la première
insémination de laquelle est né augustin
ensuite quand on a décidé d'avoir un
deuxième enfant on s'est naturellement
adressé la même technique
on a eu de nouveau un rendez vous et on
a eu donc nils et baptiste qui sont
jumeaux on a vraiment un parcours assez
atypique plupart des couples retourne
une fois deux fois trois fois voire six
et huit fois font des essais à
répétition nous on a eu beaucoup de
chance ça s'est très bien passé ça a été
très rapide
pour neil ces bâtisses tout se passe
bien à l'école même si leurs camarades
posent parfois des questions
bah c'est un exil de maman et me
demander des millions de fois quand est
ce que j'ai fait pour m normalement fait
je vois juste parce que ça chauffe
souvent posé la question
alors comment est-ce que j'ai été c'est
en et qu'est ce que tu vas bien que ses
parts ainsi en simulation ou artificiels
leur réponds d'aller vraiment le
dictionnaire
selon emmanuel et marion l'ouverture à
la pma est une avancée même s'il reste
des progrès à faire sur les droits pour
les familles homosexuelles
un couple hétérosexuel qui a recours à
mpm a fait une reconnaissance anticipée
en mairie tout simplement
un couple homosexuel devra passer par un
notaire donc devra payer un notaire on a
l'impression que c'est pour ménager
ménager certaines susceptibilités de
familles qui sont hostiles à notre
schéma familial et au fait qu'on ait
recours à la pma
donc on leur donne un petit un petit
quelque chose non non ne vous inquiétez
pas ils seront pas traités tout à fait
de la même manière pas moi ça me donne
cette impression
l'article sur l'ouverture à la pma pour
toutes les femmes a été voté en première
lecture le vendredi 27 septembre
l'examen du projet de loi relatif à la
bioéthique se poursuit au parlement une
perspective qui peut aussi déplaire une
vingtaine d'associations dont la manif
pour tous appellent à défiler contre le
projet de loi ce dimanche 6 octobre à
paris sous la bannière marchon enfants
elles ont reçu le soutien du président
de la conférence des évêques eric de
moulins beaufort
laurence rochât président de son coach
comme conseillère départementale des
yvelines est aussi élue municipale
d'opposition à lui en cours s'est
exprimé sur le plateau du 7-8 journal de
lui et de lui en fait l'adaptation de
qui fait aujourd'hui l'humanité et du
coup un dévoiement du rôle de la
médecine la médecine n'est plus là pour
réparer les corps elle est là finalement
pour les grands formés et selon un
sondage ifop en septembre dernier 65 %
des français sont favorables à une
ouverture de la bm pour toutes tes dix
pêcheurs vous êtes avec nouveau genre
bonjour vous êtes député de la première
circonscription des yvelines et vous
faites partie de la commission spéciale
chargée d'examiner le projet de loi
relatif à la bioéthique
quel regard vous portez sur cette
ouverture de la paix m déjà certains
engagements du président de la
république du programme en fait donc il
n'ya pas de n'y a pas de surprise
je pense que c'est important de rappeler
toute la concertation qui a eu sur ce
sujet parce que je vais également vice
président de l'office des sciences et
technologies et c'est cet office en fait
à l'assemblée nationale qui a été le
réceptacle du tout le travail de
consultation qui a été fait par le
conseil national d'éthique il ya eu 250
réunions publiques consultation en ligne
des français tirent au sort qui ont pu
s'exprimer
donc je pense qu'il ya eu un débat
apaisé construit réfléchit on a eu plus
de 60 heures d'audition auquel j'ai pu
participer pour se faire une idée du
sujet rencontré des familles comme on le
haut lieu on le voit dans votre
reportage la bonne âme trochut se trompe
complètement c'est qu'il n'y a pas de
manipulation du corps humain une femme
est constitué pour pouvoir enfanter un
moment donné on le voit très bien dans
le reportage que vous avez fait les
femmes allaient de toutes façons soit en
espagne soit en belgique donc s'ils en
ont les moyens financiers ce qui est
quand même très discriminant si on
regarde ça d'un peu plus près pour aller
faire la paix m
donc il n'ya pas c'est quelque chose qui
est déjà un stade dans la société
nous notre rôle en tout cas de députés
législateur c'est de remettre de
l'équité dans ce dispositif s'assurer
que toutes les femmes peuvent le faire
quelles que soient leurs moyens
financiers puisque la pma est remboursé
par la sécurité sociale et s'assurer
qu'elles le font dans des conditions
sanitaires acceptables et qu'il n'ya pas
qu'ils ne continuent pas à y avoir des
pma artisanale parce que tout le monde
ne va pas non plus en belgique ou en
espagne pour le faire il peut le faire
de manière tout à fait artisanale parce
que le corps de la femme encore une fois
peu portée des enfants sans aucune
manipulation
contrairement à ce que madame trochut
essaie de faire croire à vous parler
d'équité en septembre dernier vous avez
signé une autre tribune enfin une
tribune sur l'oeuf poste marquant votre
volonté d'ouvrir la pma ou transgenre
oui c'est ce dernier point qui n'a pas
été retenue dans le texte
je pense qu'on est sur la aussi une
évolution de la société qui nécessitent
peut-être plus de dialogue plus de
compréhension donc fallait régler le
média fallait régler deux choses
importantes l'ouvrir à l'ensemble des
femmes et s'assurer qu'on à elles en ont
parlé aussi un moment donné dans le
reportage de gérer la filiation de
simplifier les sujets de filiation vous
avez été le coeur du texte pour les
personnes transgenres donc un homme
transgenres qui était une femme
biologiquement et qui devient un homme
là aussi je voudrais dire quelque chose
d'important c'est que les personnes
transgenres en fait sont pas face à un
choix
elle décide pas un moment donné d'une
orientation identitaire ça s'impose à
elle et elle se trouve dans la situation
où elles sont nées femmes mais elle elle
se trouve être un homme dans la manière
de fonctionner au quotidien
donc c'est vrai que quelqu'un qui est
femme et qui devient un homme au sens de
l'état civil puisque bien sûr maintenant
y'a pus obligations d'opération avant on
devait s'opérer pour devenir un homme
sait plus c'est plus du tout le cas
techniquement les hommes transgenres
peuvent avoir des femmes
donc on voulait étendre on voulait
proposer en tout cas alertés sur le fait
qu'il y à déjà aujourd'hui des cas il y
a déjà des procès aujourd'hui en cours
pour trouver la filiation des enfants
qui sont nés avec des hommes transgenres
cédé qu'à quelques unités
mais la souffrance elle est là et
l'équité elle doit être aussi là pour
l'ensemble des françaises et des
français parce que derrière il ya
beaucoup cette question de la filiation
reconnaître des enfants qui sont déjà
nés mais c'est comme pour la gp avait il
s'agit pas de légaliser la gpa en france
bien entendu on y est tout à fait
opposés et qui n'est pas de
l'utilisation de marchandisation du
corps humain
maintenant de nombreux enfants sont nés
de couples d'hommes vont aux états unis
faire donc avec une mère porteuse et ont
un enfant
les enfants rentrent en france est ce
qu'on doit pénaliser les enfants parce
que ils sont nés à l'étranger d'une
mère-porteuse donc nous nous pensons et
le texte en fait va va le résoudre alors
soit par un moment il y avait un
amendement qui a été adoptée soit par un
décret de la mise de la justice ce sera
une des deux formes qui permettra de
légaliser la filiation des enfants nés
sous gpa à l'étranger
encore une fois pour que les enfants ne
soient pas pénalisés il ne s'agit
surtout pas de légaliser la gpa en
france on peut rappeler le calendrier de
ce texte
on va terminer l'examen la semaine
prochaine en tout cas l'assemblée
nationale donc il va partir ensuite au
sénat soit on se mettra d'accord sur un
texte commun et donc voilà le texte
pourrait être applicable en début
d'année soit il faudra repasser de
nouveau à l'assemblée nationale puisque
c'est toujours à l'assemblée nationale
qui a le dernier mot
je voudrais que les gens comprennent
bien en fait qu'il ya un débat d'une
très très grande qualité en commission
il ya vraiment entre les oppositions et
la majorité un débat qui est extrêmement
serein on touche à des sujets alors y'a
pas que la pma dans le texte de
bioéthique il ya aussi les dons
d'organes enfin des sujets éminemment
compliqué je pense que tout le monde
écoute respecte les points de vue de
tout le monde
mais le législateur et d'où il doit
rester sur le principe de la loi de
l'équité pour tous et essayer de ne pas
y mettre des éléments de morales qui
sont propres à chacun nous ne sommes pas
là nous n'avons pas été élus pour
représenter une morale à un moment donné
mais pour faire la loi de manière
équitable pour tout le monde on va
changer de thématiques pour parler
d'entreprise et lutte contre l'exclusion
dix mille participants accompagnés 2000
collaborateurs d'entreprises engagées et
68% de retour à l'emploi
le bilan des 20 ans de fass yvelines un
anniversaire célébré ce jeudi 3 octobre
au théâtre national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines des
parlementaires des élus locaux des chefs
d'entreprise et des personnes
accompagnées par le club étaient
présents
tout a commencé en 1999 la communauté
d'agglomération avec des sociétés du
territoire a créé face saint quentin en
yvelines devenu face yvelines en 2006 le
président national de fass gérald
mestrallet étaient présents à cette
cérémonie tout comme agnès gladys
salarié chez suez un groupe partenaire
de phase iib flynn on les écoute au
micro de nicolas landry je suis toujours
très agrément surpris de voir le nombre
de personnes dans les entreprises mais
aussi chez les collectivités locales
qu'il souhaite tendre la main confie si
nous sommes dans un arbre
à un club ancien tonique qui a fait ses
preuves
et qu'ils continuent sur une très belle
dynamique didier baichère vous avez
justement c'est le plan 1000 jeunes un
partenariat avec sa sylvine comment se
traduit cette action sur le département
et 50 en huile donc c'est un plan qui
vise à placer en tout cas mille jeunes
en cdi dans des délais alors on a mené
sur 12 mois puis le plan a été reconduit
pour 24 mois donc deux fois douze mois
supplémentaires
compte tenu du succès c'est un plan en
fait qui permet avec face en
l'occurrence puisque c'est vrai que sur
saint quentin en yvelines c'est que le
fasse en fait qui est notre partenaire
principal de mettre autour de la table
l'ensemble des acteurs de l'emploi aussi
bien là ces pme que le medef que la
chambre de commerce mais que les acteurs
beaucoup plus institutionnel que son
pôle emploi la mission locale et fasse
en fait va un moment donné par sa
connaissance en fait des difficultés
sociales que peuvent avoir les jeunes de
quartiers enfin issus de quartiers
politique de la ville va faire ce lien
l'intermédiation entre les entreprises
et les jeunes qui cherchent un emploi
l'université de versailles saint quentin
et est un partenaire aussi très
intéressant de du plan 1000 jeunes ce
qui a beaucoup de jeunes de trappes qui
vont à l'université et qui
malheureusement compte tenu des
discriminations de là où ils habitent
souvent un pas à pas uniquement on pense
à la couleur de peau ou non mais aussi
parce que nous habite à trappes se
trouvent dans des situations de
discrimination donc le plan 1000 jeunes
visa à remettre ensemble à la fois les
entreprises qui cherchent à recruter
parce qu'on est sur un vrai dynamisme
économique en ce moment et nous ont dit
bah écoutez vous avez un moyen de
diversifier votre sourcing en allant
chercher des jeunes que vous connaissez
- mais qui sont prêts à l'emploi parce
que quand une fois les jeunes qui
habitent attrapé qui sortent diplômés de
l'université de versailles-saint-quentin
ils sont parfaitement prêt à l'emploi
par contre ils n'osent peut-être pas
aller vers des entreprises comme je
pense est inédit je pense à deux co qui
sont des partenaires bouygues
construction qui sont des grands
partenaires de l'opération du plan 1000
jeunes et qui est heureux kruth et qui
sont prêts à s'engager dans la lutte
contre les discriminations vous restez
avec nous on va passer à l'essentiel de
l'actualité de la semaine
[Musique]
ce lundi 30 octobre était journée de
deuil national en hommage à jacques
chirac
les obsèques se sont tenues à paris
cérémonie privée aux invalides suivie
d'une messe à l'église saint sulpice une
minute de silence était observée dans
les écoles et les institutions à 15
heures un hommage largement suivie dans
les yvelines
comme vous le voyez sur ces images dans
les mairies de trappes et montigny le
bretonneux hommage républicain également
à poissy en fin de journée sur le parvis
de l'hôtel de ville une centaine de
personnes ya assisté
minute de silence et discours en
présence du préfet des yvelines de
plusieurs maires et de la députée de la
circonscription
didier baichère quels souvenirs vous
gardez de jacques chirac ben moi en
termes de génération c'est vrai que
jacques chirac sait que bien qu'ils
étaient présents une très grande partie
de ma vie quand on parlait de politique
entend parler d'élection c'est vrai que
moi je vois jacques chirac sur les
marchés rencontrer les gens être proche
du peuple quelque part donc c'est un peu
l'image que je garde de jacques chirac
mais je pense que ce qui était important
sur cet hommage c'est aussi quelque part
l'hommage de la république et la musique
de la minute de silence pardon dont dans
les écoles ou dans les entreprises dans
les institutions
ça me semblait important aussi pour se
rappeler que président de la république
c'est lui qui représente la république
et que c'est quelque chose qui est très
précieux et finalement on a beaucoup de
chance en france d'être dans une
république et je pense que ces moments
ils sont importants pour la cohésion
nationale dans le reste de l'actualité
cette semaine les policiers en colère ça
n'était pas arrivé depuis 2001 27 mille
agents des forces de l'ordre étaient
dans la rue mercredi à paris à l'appel
d'une intersyndicale mobilisation pour
préserver leur régime spécifique de
retraite mais aussi sous fond
d'inquiétude en raison des conditions de
travail se dégradent de plus en plus de
fonctionnaires démissionnent ou pire en
arrive tôt suicide en un an dans les
yvelines quatre policiers ont mis fin à
leurs jours
on écoute je viens le cam secrétaire
régional du syndicat alliance police
nationale qui s'est exprimé dans le 7-8
journal pour le 60 18 notamment nous
montrent tous manifesté sur paris pour
le manque d'effectifs
il ya de grands manques d'effectifs sur
le département des yvelines
d'ailleurs depuis le week-end dernier on
peut voir que plus de la moitié des
effectifs de police secours du comice
adversaires sont en arrêt maladie
nous avons des tas de gens du
qui pourrissent le quotidien de nos
collègues faut savoir que la guerre de
la lanterne sur versailles par exemple
mobilis trois véhicules tous les
week-ends de police secours
il ya aussi pour alerter l'opinion
publique car il faut savoir que la
profession est victime d'actes violents
qui se banalise on peut le voir aussi
depuis deux week-ends sur plaisir mes
collègues sont attaqués par des groupes
d'individus et c'est un phénomène qui
est très inquiétant une profession
d'autant plus endeuillé suite à une
attaque jeudi midi à la préfecture de
police à paris
un agent de cette préfecture a attaqué
plusieurs policiers au couteau une femme
et trois hommes sont morts un autre
policier gravement blessé l'assaillant
un agent administratif de la préfecture
de police a été abattu
le parquet de paris a ouvert a confié
l'enquêté à la brigade criminelle
teddy richert comment prendre en compte
ces revendications des policiers cool
comme on l'a entendu dans l'extrait
c'est un moment qui est important on va
rentrer dans la période budgétaire vous
savez qu'on en fait ce qui se passe
c'est qu'il ya eu cette diminution de -
de plus de douze mille policiers qui ont
été supprimés des postes qui ont été
supprimés dans les mandatures
précédentes
donc nous on s'est engagé sur un plan de
recrutement ambitieux pour combler les
manques en effectifs humains mais aussi
pour combler énormément de vous avez par
exemple j'essaie de vous prendre des
exemples concrets le déploiement de 8000
tablettes et smartphones pour pour la
police aujourd'hui les policiers sont
pas aussi bien équipés que vous et moi
pour faire leur travail à 230 millions
ceux qui sont sur la table pour revoir
tous les équipements de de la police
nationale vous avez 300 millions qui
sont également prévus au budget pour
rénover les commissariats parce que les
conditions de travail sont difficiles
je pense qu'il ya une fois les français
ils aiment leurs cent cinquante mille
policiers ils sont ils savent le travail
au quotidien qu'ils font et on a besoin
de vos quotidiens maintenant il ya bien
une fonction je pense qui a été laissé
de côté pendant de très nombreuses
années et qui il faut rattraper ce
retard avec les différents budgets
c'est ce qu'on fait depuis qu'on a été
élu d'un protocole d'accord qui a été
signé avec les syndicats aussi pour une
revisite valorisation des salaires des
policiers
tout ça c'est des choses qui sont en
marche qui vont continuer à travers les
différents budgets sur les sur les cinq
ans du mandat de
vous avez parlé d' aide matérielle mais
à versailles notamment comme l'expliqué
julien le cam
plusieurs policiers se sont mis en arrêt
maladie pour protester contre leur garde
donc à versailles à la lanterne pour le
président de la république et aussi à
renvoyer pour le président du sénat
chaque week-end ils sont obligés de
faire avec car ce qu'ils sont assez
nombreux qu'est-ce qu'ils sont assez
nombreux je pense que ce n'est pas aussi
simple qu'il prenne quelque chose
d'emblématique parce qu'il se trouve que
dans les yvelines ils ont les deux
premières personnalités de l'étang
français donc ils prennent cet exemple
là je pense que la question de leur
planning est sur la table la question de
l'organisation de la police de manière
générale et sur la table donc c'est à
des recrutements qui sont en cours il y
en aura plus de 2000 cette année pour
aller renforcer
je pense qu'à la revalorisation aussi du
métier de policier qui est qui est sur
la table que savent castaner a été très
clair ces jours derniers puisqu'il a
parlé de reconnaître la dangerosité du
métier des policiers
donc c'est aussi un message à leur
rencontre pour dire que finalement quand
ils vont toucher leur retraite puisque
c'était une de leurs revendications
il y aura de la considération avec cette
dangerosité donc du volume de retraite
qui pourront en touche et donc une
amélioration de leur retraite donc on
les entend et on essaye de prendre des
décisions concrètes pour les aider dans
leur quotidien
autre manifestation de fonctionnaires
avec les enseignants des rassemblements
organisés dans tout les yvelines jeudi
en hommage à christine renom cette
directrice d'école du 93 qui s'est donné
la mort fin septembre dans une lettre
quelques jours avant son suicide adressé
aux 25 directeurs d'école de pantin et à
son syndicat elles dénonçaient des
conditions de travail de plus en plus
difficiles à trappes devant l'école
primaire henri wallon une centaine
d'enseignants étaient mobilisés à la
mi-journée lecture de la lettre de
christine renaud et minute de silence
on écoute les réactions au micro de
michael et demi d'euros la situation de
monsieur renaud témoigne effectivement
de sept de ses difficultés des collègues
dans leurs conditions de travail et des
conditions de travail dégradées et on a
l'impression qu'il faut que
l'administration fait ne prend pas en
compte tous les directeurs de trappes
ont ce sentiment en lisant sa lettre on
a tous eu l'impression qu'elle décrivait
ce qu'on vivait et ben tout peut
basculer du jour au lendemain quand on
est un peu moins fort une marche blanche
de la mairie de pantin jusqu'à l'école
de christine renaud est organisée ce
samedi 5 octobre en hommage
une directrice d'école qui se suicident
sur son lieu de travail c'est un symbole
fort et directeurs d'école manque de
soutien dans leurs fonctions
mais malheureusement au suicide c'est
dans beaucoup de professions donc c'est
toujours un moment qui est terrible et
ce cas là est particulièrement difficile
je pense qu'on a pris là aussi la mesure
de la difficulté quand on a décidé dès
2017 de dédoubler dans les zones
d'éducation prioritaire les classes de
cp et de ce1 donc c'est vraiment diviser
par deux la classe et quand on voit les
résultats qui aujourd'hui c'est pour
l'apprentissage des enfants mais c'est
aussi pour les conditions de travail des
enseignants
on a clairement indiqué qu'on visait un
maximum de 24 enfants par classe
donc ça c'est l'objectif le budget de
l'éducation nationale aujourd'hui c'est
le budget qui progresse le plus
depuis 2010 est il ya encore des efforts
à faire
je pense qu'il ya un travail de
coordination des couteaux ci avec les
enseignants à mener mais tant qu'on
n'arrivera pas à diminuer encore une
fois c'est notre objectif d'arriver à
ces 24 élèves par classe on sait qu'on
aura toujours des conditions de travail
qui seront difficiles pour les
enseignants une page économie et santé
maintenant fin 2018 la cpm a mis en
place une plateforme en ligne de dépôt
d'idées avec pour ambition de faire
évoluer leurs services proposés la cpm a
ouvert ses portes aux assurés afin de
leur montrer le parcours d'une feuille
de soins reportage d'emmanuel d'eau et
patrick jacques de dixmude à la caisse
primaire d'assurance maladie des
yvelines la cpam
une visite des coulisses d'une feuille
de soins papier est organisé son délai
moyen de traitement est d'environ 20
jours en 2018 une plateforme en ligne de
recueil d'idées a été ouverte pendant
trois mois autour de divers thèmes
cela a permis de recueillir près de 300
idée d'assurer blinois dans les grandes
villes mais aussi dans la campagne on si
je vends mes grands parents
la difficulté c'est l'accès au soin et
je pense qu'un service public à une
mission si de pouvoir localiser des
médecins de proximité peut-être des
spécialistes pour apporter ses services
de santé même si les documents reçus par
voie postale sont minoritaires les
visiteurs ont pu découvrir lors de la
visite que c'est un flux important pour
la cpam une gestion optimale est
obligatoire après 2011 encore
aujourd'hui du papier je m'attendais à
trouver quand même des choses un peu
plus dématérialisé que c'est les assurés
ont pu échanger sur la caisse primaire
d'assurance maladie de demain le
traitement d'une feuille de soins papier
coûte 1 euro
74 contre 27 centimes pour la version
électronique l'assurance maladie des
yvelines estime qu'on pourrait
économiser plus de 3,8 millions d'euros
par an le papier représente à peu près 6
% notre activité mais c'est 6 %
d'activité c'est quand même 144 millions
de documents reçus tous les jours donc
c'est en fait très conséquent
effectivement il ya un enjeu fort à
pouvoir dématérialisée au maximum ses 6
% qui restent au delà des économies la
dématérialisation permet aux patients en
moins de démarches un meilleur délai de
remboursement
la cpam des yvelines envisage de
réaliser des consultations régulières
auprès des assurés une dématérialisation
la vue qui permet entre autres de
réduire les coûts le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale a été
présenté mercredi en conseil des
ministres le retour à l'équilibré qui
était prévu pour cette année est
finalement reportée à 2023
pourquoi cette marche arrière dans un
contexte de rigueur budgétaire
ce n'est pas une marche ailleurs c'est
très très clair vous avez pour le
département des yvelines + 29 % de
personnes qui bénéficient de la prime
d'activité donc que nous avons augmenté
élargi en début d'année donc forcément
vous avez une dérive du budget de la
sécurité sociale puisqu'il est il est
pris à cet endroit donc c'est quelque
chose qu'on assume complètement parce
qu'il fallait revoir cette prime
d'activité donc l'équilibré lieu de
cette année il sera repoussé à 2023
mais je pense que les personnes qui ont
vu leur pouvoir d'achat augmenter grâce
à cette semaine d'activités sont
probablement très très content notre
entretien se termine ici didier leschi
remercie dadié sur notre plateau toute
la semaine nous avons exploré les traces
du cinéma sur nos terres yvelinois
vous pouvez retrouver notre 7,8 dossier
consacré au cinéma sur internet et notre
application mobile l'occasion de revenir
en 2006 après un casting dans
l'agglomération saint-quentinoise le
réalisateur jean pierre mocky posé ses
caméras dans l'ancienne bibliothèque
universitaire locaux aujourd'hui détruit
ceux situés à proximité de la gare de
montigny le bretonneux
c'est notre rubrique ça s'est passé
[Musique]
château on en sait un peu plus sur le
deal dont le tournage est en cours à
l'ancienne bibliothèque universitaire de
saint quentin en yvelines
à commencer par le casting jean françois
stévenin il fera une apparition
sont également présents jean claude
dreyfus figure emblématique de
delicatessen ou encore alison arngrim
alias nellie oleson dans la petite
maison dans la prairie
enfin on compte deux autres fidèles du
metteur en scène
jackie berroyer et dominique marty alors
mon personnage est un enquêteur qui
s'appelle castan et qui d'ailleurs que
porte le même nom et le même look que
dans un autre film de mots qui dans
lequel j'ai tourné qui s'appelle la bête
la bête de miséricorde
mon personnage est déjà dans la
continuité de ce que dans lesquelles
j'ai toujours joué les fantômes à celle
et belphégor et vidéos etc
puisque je les ai tous faits depuis 50
ans je joue tous les malfaisants tous
les torts du tout les touches heures du
pcci tous les tarés possibles et
imaginables
quant au scénario il serait inspiré de
celui de menaces sorti en 1939
une histoire de sans papiers dans une
français des années 30 hermétique aux
nouveaux et à l'inconnu
les premiers tours de manivelle du deal
ont été donnés en début de semaine et le
film devrait être présenté en ouverture
du prochain festival du polar dans la
ville dans une dizaine de mois
mais au rythme où se tourner les scènes
entre réécriture du scénario et coup de
sang du réalisateur rien n'est moins sûr
il ya des aspects
à divers gémeaux qui l on croit qu'un
peu on est compliment qu'on fait sur lui
les reproches sont aussi longs tout
aussi fondées mais c'est un ensemble il
faut prendre le tout quoi
[Musique]
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
nous avoir suivi on se quitte sur des
images aquatique de julie peugeot une
plaisir oise et du mi6 rennes un
reportage à retrouver dès la semaine
prochaine sur notre antenne du week end
sur tv 78 quand les souvenirs s'emmêle
les larmes me viennent et le chant des
sirènes me replonge en hiver au
l'ancolie cruel
harmonie fluet
deux forts et solitaire
[Musique]